[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM BRAY: Hello, there.
Happy Valentine's
Day, everybody.
Welcome to Identity
Hoodoo Voodoo on
Google Developers Live.
I'm Tim Bray.
I'm with the identity group
here at Google.
And today with me, I have Naveen
Agarwal, who's a tech
lead, manager, something
important here in the group.
And he's been doing identity
stuff for at least 100 years.
Naveen, give us some
highlights.
NAVEEN AGARWAL: 100 years.
Well, if you include all the
team members and so on,
definitely we've been doing
this for 100 years.
So I've been at Google
for two years.
Before that, roughly for nine
years, I was managing the
identity team at Yahoo!, where
we did OpenID launch, a lot of
things which were completely
unknown, browser-based auth
and OAuth 1.0 extension, for
example, which was Yahoo's
extension, which essentially
became OAuth 2.0 for the
bearer flows, and so on.
On Google side, in the last two
years, we've been making
things much, much easier, trying
to integrate seamlessly
into different platforms and
making the experience overall
much easier, and make things
better for our users and allow
them to share and do what
they want to do.
TIM BRAY: So increasingly,
a lot of our users
are on mobile devices.
And that's what I want us
to talk about today.
Mobile devices are super
important, because in lots of
parts of the world, that's the
only way onto the internet.
And even in this part of the
world, an increasing
proportion of time is
on mobile devices.
And passwords already suck.
And on mobile devices, the whole
identity thing can be
very painful.
So what can we tell developers
right now today?
NAVEEN AGARWAL: I think
you're right.
We understand the identity
issues are not that easy on
the mobile devices.
Almost all the flows which have
been developed, they were
based on the browser.
They were assuming that the
user was in a browser, the
bigger approval pages,
and so on.
So we are trying to make the
experience much, much better.
And we have actually been
able to do a lot
on the Android side.
And you actually log in once.
And you don't really have to
enter password a second time.
It's very rare, even, that you
have to enter a password.
And we have found it's much
easier to do all these,
because there are different
security properties.
Users hold their phones
next to them.
You're not sharing
a phone a lot.
And so there are some nicer
things which come with the
phone, so you can actually
log the user.
And they have an expectation.
And they don't want
to sign out.
In the desktop, people
do sign out.
And again, the protocols were
written assuming the browser.
So they do not really fall
nicely into the Android and
the iOS operating systems.
But we have been making
nicer changes.
And in Android, if you look at
the OAuth 2.0 implementation
we have, it has nothing
about OAuth 2.0.
Developer doesn't have to
understand OAuth 2.0.
You just make a call to the
[INAUDIBLE], say, give me a
token for these codes,
and you get a token.
And you can use it.
TIM BRAY: So that's
the good news.
But there's the other
operating system.
And you mentioned it.
Many of our folks use Apples,
use iPhones, and
iPads, and so on.
And we're still struggling a
little bit harder on there.
In fact, I know people who have
iOS devices complain at
me about, specifically, the
Google apps and having to sign
in all the time.
So what are we doing
about that?
NAVEEN AGARWAL: I think it
is hard given that we--
it requires support from
the operating system.
All of our apps require user to
sign in, if you basically
have personalized experience.
And essentially, you have to
enter ID and password each and
every app, which is really
painful for a user.
And imagine if you are
a two-factor user.
You have to enter ID,
password, and an
OTP in every app.
TIM BRAY: And you should
be a two-factor user.
If you're not, get on that.
Sorry, go on.
NAVEEN AGARWAL: Yes, I think
that's a very good point.
There is no reason-- if you have
anything valuable in your
account, any email coming in,
you should actually sign up
for two-factor.
But given that, that's
basically very hard.
We definitely want to have the
single sign-on work fairly
easily between all the apps.
And we are working
on that part.
So stayed tuned.
But I think that developers have
even a harder time, even
on the iOS.
So we have been actually looking
at some of the options
to make life easier for
developers to get OAuth token,
given that on iOS, you don't
have background apps.
You cannot talk to them
in the background.
So it's much, much harder,
basically, to do.
TIM BRAY: So have we got
anything specific we can talk
about right now?
NAVEEN AGARWAL: Right.
So on the iOS, currently, there
are a couple of options
if you want to get an OAuth
token for Google APIs.
One, which is the Google+
SDK, and which is
actually very easy--
one of the best parts is if the
user is signed into the
Google+ App, you ask
for a token.
He's going to see an approval
page, no password entry.
And user says yes, you
get a code back.
And basically, it's
a permanent code.
You can store it.
TIM BRAY: But lots of people
don't have that app.
NAVEEN AGARWAL: Right.
But the good part is G+ SDK
actually will default back to
the native browser,
Safari browser.
And so if the app doesn't exist,
it'll actually send the
user to the browser.
And again, if the user has to
just sign in once into Google
in the browser, and they will
see an approval page, and
they'll click on the approval
page and basically go back to
the app, which is a very nice,
smooth experience.
You could actually do this.
Now we have recently enabled--
you could actually make a call
directly sent to the browser
without using the G+ SDK if
there are certain things which
you may need which is not there
through the G+ SDK.
TIM BRAY: So this has
been working.
But we haven't been talking
about it very much yet.
NAVEEN AGARWAL: Right.
We haven't talked about this.
But it is actually now live.
You could actually try it out.
And I do have an app if you
want to see the experience
where you could actually
send the user
to the Safari browser.
If they're signed into Google,
they would just see an
approval page.
User says yes.
And they will get the code
back to your app.
And you're signed in.
TIM BRAY: Should we be brave
and try for a live demo?
NAVEEN AGARWAL: We could try.
We could give it a try
and see how it works.
TIM BRAY: Switch over
to the iPad there.
So I have an app here
which actually
has signed into Google.
If I click on it, you can see
it goes to the Safari.
I will sign into Safari.
I see an approval page.
And if I say allow access,
smoothly it
goes back to the app.
And app has access
to the data.
And it actually can fetch
whatever it needs, basically.
AUDIENCE: Can you do
that one more time?
We were not set yet.
NAVEEN AGARWAL: Sure
AUDIENCE: One second.
All right.
Do it again.
NAVEEN AGARWAL: So here we have
the app, which basically
has signed into Google.
You click on Sign In.
It sends you back to the
browser, where I'm signed into
the browser.
I see an approval page.
It's asking for some of the
basic information about my
Google account.
I say Allow Access.
The code is sent back
to the app.
And app can use that
access token to
actually fetch the data.
So it's a pretty smooth
experience,
actually, to make it work.
So you could--
I dropped the mic.
TIM BRAY: That happened last
time I did this, too.
AUDIENCE: Leave it on.
NAVEEN AGARWAL: So the other
options are-- which actually,
currently, people use--
are using embedded web view.
And there was no easier option
for our developers on iOS.
And embedded web views work
nicely from a user experience.
But actually, one of the biggest
drawbacks is user has
to enter ID and password in each
and every app, which is
really painful.
I hate entering passwords on my
mobile devices, even though
it's easier to type them in.
But depending on how many
characters and numbers I have,
it's very hard.
So generally, embedded
view might look good.
People generally like
them using our
GTM OAuth 2.0 library.
But they definitely are not
the best experience from a
user point of view, because they
have to keep entering the
ID and password again
and again.
TIM BRAY: So after we decided
to do this talk--
Naveen actually published
a few slides on what you
actually have to do as an iOS
developer to make this happen.
Could we switch to the
Chromebook just for a sec
there, Dylan?
And they're linked from Naveen's
Google+ page and my
Google+ page.
So if you just go to Google+
and type Tim Bray or Naveen
Agarwal, you'll find a
link to this thing.
And there's this trick where
you actually register a
callback URI where the scheme
identifies your app by either
bundle or client ID.
NAVEEN AGARWAL: Right.
So in order to support the--
so essentially, what we did
not have a way from a browser
to get back to the app.
And by the way, this works not
just in Safari or iOS.
It works in other operating
system for the native apps.
What we are supporting now is
that we will redirect back.
If your app is a native app,
or installed app, we would
redirect back to one of the
custom URL which you provide.
Custom URL could be a
bundle ID on iOS.
So for example, you can
see com.example.myapp.
And you need to provide that
bundle ID to us when you
register that client ID.
Or in cases on some operating
system where you don't have
bundle ID or anything else, you
could just use the reverse
of your client ID as
the custom URL.
So you can see in this one,
client ID is 1234-abc.apps.go
ogleusercontent.com.
We would basically select
one of them.
You can pass that as a redirect
URI in the call to
the browser.
And if all this matches
out, we'll redirect
back after the approval.
TIM BRAY: So that's
up there now.
We eventually will roll this
out into the regular
documentation suite.
But it's there, and
it's working.
And you're encouraged to go
ahead and give it a try.
So let's go back to Android
for a second, where
everything's built in
and easy for us.
We've been working on basically
minimizing the approvals.
NAVEEN AGARWAL: Yes.
I think one of the things, when
we started with OAuth, or
even with OpenID, we were very
approval page trigger-happy,
what I would call it, basically,
putting lots of
stuff on the approval pages,
trying to make sure that user
is very well-aware of.
What it basically has created
is that user may click on
approval page without even
thinking about it, or they're
seeing the approval
pages very often.
And they don't understand
what's going on.
So we are trying to minimize
the number of times we show
user approval pages, or where
it's not really needed, and we
can actually infer that user is
actually trying to do the
right thing.
And one of the things which we
did recently on Android was
where the user is trying to get
an ID token to log into
their own web server,
essentially, if the user has
selected an email address from
the account manager, then he
is saying yes.
I want to actually use this
account to log in.
There is no approval page.
And we give out an ID token,
which essentially gets you
access to an ID token and also
their public Google profile
information to that user.
TIM BRAY: Basically, what we're
trying to do is to ask
the user for permission only
when it's reasonable and it's
worthy of their attention.
So if I'm using some developer's
Android app, if I
also want to identify myself to
their back end, I shouldn't
have to ask for permission
again.
They should do that.
So we've been making some--
NAVEEN AGARWAL: So I think we--
just to also clarify, we
have also done this
on the web.
So in certain flows, if you know
the user's email address,
and if you pass that email
address to an auth end point,
and if you are only requesting
an email scope, we would
actually not show an approval
page if the user is signed in.
And we'll send you back an ID
token which you can verify
that the user is signed in.
So you could use that
to actually verify
user's email address.
Without sending them an email,
you could actually do that
fairly easily, because the user
had entered the email
address on your side.
And you redirect back.
And so there are lots of good
use cases you will see in the
future we may be enabling.
TIM BRAY: So identity
on the internet is--
the internet's huge.
And the identity problem on
the internet is huge.
It feels, sometimes, like we're
facing this incredibly
tall mountain in
the Himalayas.
But we are inching up.
And the idea is to keep people
safe and secure and not pester
them all the time, because
that's part of
security, as well.
So we're running a little
bit long here.
Dylan, unless there's somebody
online with a question, I
think we should maybe
call it a day.
And we're good.
Fair enough.
So thanks for dropping
in and listening.
And we'll be doing these on a
regular basis, so come back
for more identity good news
and nastiness, as well, on
Google Developers Live.
Thank you kindly.
NAVEEN AGARWAL: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]